[Music]
and that's my news that's my pop I gotta
pay spot bails submitted by let me treat
you to dinner well who are you then
nope because there's some fans that I
just don't want to spend too much time
with I'm in dinner some of them are
really cool but some of them I love that
you support us that's all I got to say
so relatable a man was arrested after
shooting his cousin over salt and
vinegar potato chips those are good oh
yeah salt and vinegar potato chips are
the [ __ ] [ __ ] the kale cooked once
all brother heavy rain it's texture on
her have you tried the dill pickle
flavoured potato chips we can't the hell
out of here yeah I actually did and I
didn't like you do like there's normally
people like vinegar but it didn't taste
like they're not it's like sweet dill
Trader Joe's bran what Americans do
today with chips is why I love this
country yeah it's like [ __ ] I want
loaded potato chips yeah we we innovate
everyone's food like subculture invents
a food we take it and then we'll make it
bigger
who else has good chips oh the UK does
have really good chips french fries or
potato crisps thank you yes you thank
you sorry but like they have like when
we were in France actually we had chips
from the UK and it was like ham and
cheese sandwich flavour chips not like
they know what's up out here like they
have good [ __ ] but they still that from
but there's more from us though the beer
that beer sucks shit's weak Japanese
[ __ ] also really delicious
Oh Japanese potato chip some crazy ass
just to show you guys how good eating
it's a mukbang now don't you know those
do really well by the way all right
Japanese chip mukbang so this this man
he
apparently he told his cousin once his
cousin got near his potato chips he's
like don't you dare eat those don't you
eat my god they ever dated you do not
touch my chips or I'll shoot you is what
he said well let me ask you why told him
how many people are remaining in his
mouth I'm pretty sure in Florida it's
completely legal to kill someone if you
told about no I'm saying in the state of
Florida I think it is actually
completely legitimate yeah this one took
place in South Carolina so not very
close very very close thinking well they
migrated North Florida yes so this
dude's name is Ryan he's 19 years old
this is what he looks like they did that
shot there's you better not go to jail
he warned the guy he looks like she
likes ICP early in life that's not
balding do that gonna get a healthy
hairline of mine tell you that right now
I'll kill for that hairline dude you and
Logan Paul would kill that damn dude
that'd be cold my dude Logan are you
kidding me bro amen 32 attitude
available no yelling I'm gonna watch it
happen you plug hear me yeah give me an
opening yeah all right so he critically
wounded his 70-mile cousin because after
he told them like don't you don't touch
my chips so then he went into the back
room he got a rifle and pointed it at
the victim and then the next thing they
knew it went off but did he touch the
chips I know you got the chill this is
what he was doing though this is what he
was doing he goes oh really that's
exactly what [ __ ] it seven chip because
it wasn't about the chips it was about
the [ __ ] yeah respect that's how
I know you weren't an only child licked
it that [ __ ] is like my whole [ __ ] gun
you use man yes if you have siblings
like food wars is [ __ ] real man I
used to play a game with my neighborhood
kids I was like the leader of my
neighborhood group of kids oh yeah and
so I would
I would be like okay we're playing like
the monster game again and like okay
cool
and the monster game was they just go to
their kitchens bring me food and they
feed the monster the same age as me so
you're like pretending to be a monster
exactly baby hot cheeto oh it was great
thank you yeah I just been the violent
kid that if you mentioned that I was not
throwing [ __ ] at you or I would've been
like how come I can't be a monster too
really I pick that's not the gate
there's only one monster it's always me
it was other people didn't want to be
the monster to know they would just play
the game like monster I don't get
monster it was fun did you do sound like
10 would you be like it was fun for all
yeah so initially when the cousin was
taken to the hospital
the pool because you know every time
there's like a shooting whatever like
the concept do game balls would thing to
find out what happened exactly and so
they told the police that he had the 17
year old had accidentally shot himself
by dropping a hunting rifle while
cleaning it but then the more that the
officers investigated into this they
were like wait that me that's impossible
like the way like the ballistics you're
just like there's no way like he would
have shot himself accident also they
were after he did it was like all right
Cletus just tell me who shot yourself
all right it's gonna be really yeah
because yeah the victim confirmed that
that story to know a week later a victim
and woken up and he you pretty much told
the investigators that yeah Kato chips
were at the center of this you should
have never told us that yeah your first
story man what if everyone in this town
is dumb and they're like oh damn it you
two
my potato chips again huh I should have
known for me it was barbecue mm-hmm boy
the 17-year old like he was like in and
out of like almost making it he was he
was shot in the chest oh [ __ ] well good
thing you survived because we can live
to joke about it exactly thank you that
kid just wanted an excuse to shoot his
gun well he just has a gun he never gets
to use it a rifle - it's like gives me
like he has a taste for blood I feel
like they hadn't been drunk or something
like I don't you know like I don't think
they were or just too much testosterone
there's like their hormones are crazy
when you're 19 17 or 18 I bet you guys
so dub he'll come out right now say how
dare you say I was drunk I was
completely coherent you know why Nicky
has this has this line of defense
because one time her brother ate her
Lucky Charms
no it was pretty public for Fruity
Pebbles so she was because she came home
to get her fruity pebbles that she had
just gotten and the whole box had been
beaten and put back and put back and
that will piss me off so she so she went
all the way to [ __ ] school yeah cuz I
was screaming out of high school and my
brother was still in high school so I
was home and then he was his lunch break
and I went out of his classroom and then
I another bowl of cereal already could
have been back home I've been saving
these lucky fruity pebbles because they
were like I was saving them that hook I
couldn't consume thinking about them all
day long I was thinking about a
vegetable bugs
exactly my cousin did that one time she
ate all of our I just gotten send them
to his crunches she ate the whole
[ __ ] thing and then she tore the box
into pieces and put it in a trash can so
I couldn't find it anywhere and I was
like
she was a psycho bud how'd you find her
my mom found it my mom was taking the
trash out and she saw the on the side of
the bag she could see it there like a
big red see you saying she should have
been in the middle I feel like you found
her out because you start throwing up
cinnamon toast clearly it was you know
cuz I was asked my mom she threw out
anywhere not even all right anywhere I
don't understand yeah what caused this
yeah I wouldn't driven somewhere oh oh I
was raging it was all so PMS weak and my
blood was just boiling under this under
my skin I don't know if you get really
bad PMS but help me I need to like rages
don't you [ __ ] ever just eat a whole
box of cereal in that house dude
sometimes when we're Nikki's like this
it's like I'm sweating and I'm disarming
a bomb but it's like it's about to go
off somewhere just focus on it and it's
like Oh God
do you get really moody during but
during when Tom comes around my and it's
also like I know that I'm acting
irrational and I'll even voice it like
and like I know that I'm being a [ __ ]
but like I just can't help it it's just
like it's just like under my skin it
just feels like my entire body is hot
and I just need to like yell I do scream
you should really take up martial arts
so you can just start punching the [ __ ]
David stop trying to get all the girls
to sign up for one idea she doesn't even
fight it'll help next Friday
you're gonna learn take one dose know it
helps with aggression like a lot you're
doing that I'm not doing it I don't know
she's aggressive exactly how to beat him
up when I'm he'll be there
raging bunny her now is so easy and fun
yeah no I don't rage at all what do you
don't even lie he's lying right
so much no no you know I don't raise you
guys me as a puppet it makes me rage
when she's on pages my age either I was
sure I heard it's an ethnic thing I
heard like a like a lot of ethnic women
it's that Gazzola my whole Filipino side
is exactly the same way like all the
animal inside I'll meet all of me me and
all of my cousins are like that but my
mom and my white cousins are not like
that now I'm trying to make it to a race
thing but I don't know what it is so I
have a white sister who would disagree
with you rage the [ __ ] on out all a lot
of really mean white girls really [ __ ]
Reggie very boy I don't think mmm yeah
well it's a lot of KC on you for a
second we'll see yeah yeah Casey Wilson
will be like this no she doesn't like
the guys you guys have your PMS week
sometimes dude my sister was Hulkamania
running wild all over the house bro
there this bit sits
oh really oh yeah yeah yeah
[Music]